[Music]
you've likely heard the story of lucifer
the fallen angel according to christian
legend
lucifer was the most senior and most
beautiful angel in god's heavenly court
he wanted to be more powerful than god
and rebelled along with some other
corrupted angels
after ensuing heavenly war lucifer and
other angels were banished from heaven
and descended all the way down to hell
lucifer now a fallen angel became the
devil
his fellow fallen angels became demons
okay with me so far good the story you
just heard
is not in the bible well at least not in
the way it's often
told the real origin of lucifer is a lot
more interesting
it's actually one of misinformation
conflation
and one very curious mistranslation
let me explain before we get into wars
in heaven
fallen angels and hellfire let's start
with his name
lucifer it's just one of many names used
for the devil
like satan and the beast and those names
are used quite a lot of times in the
bible
but only once is the name lucifer ever
mentioned
and that's in the old testament's book
of isaiah in chapter 14 verse 12 of the
book
the prophet isaiah says this how you are
fallen from heaven o lucifer
son of the morning how you are cut down
to the ground
you who weakened the nations even though
the name lucifer is mentioned
this taunting remark is actually
directed towards the arrogant king of
babylon
whose kingdom had just been destroyed
isaiah is basically teasing him for it
so how you fallen o lucifer's son of the
morning
kind of just means king of babylon oh
look how the mighty have fallen
but why did isaiah need to call him
lucifer what satan got to do with any of
this
well you might say lucifer was
ungraciously cast down from heaven as
well
so likening the king of babylon to
lucifer is actually a pretty good
comparison here
and yes you would be right but the thing
is
if you examine the text in its original
language isaiah
was never really making this comparison
in the first place
when we read the same text in its
original language biblical hebrew
isaiah's taunt actually sounds a bit
like this eknapalta mishamayim hail
benjakha
did you hear me say the word lucifer no
nowhere does the real isaiah actually
say this name instead it be called
lucifer
the king of babylon is called he'll be
literally a shining one son of morning
in hebrew
a shining one son of morning does not
refer to satan or the devil
but a planet the planet venus otherwise
known as the morning star
besides the moon venus is the brightest
body in the night sky
and because it's so bright it's often
the first star
that can be seen in the evening and the
last star you can see when the sun comes
up
hence the name the morning star or in
hebrew
shining one son of mourning
so back to isaiah is taunted about the
morning star and it all begins to make
sense if applied to the planet venus
by describing the king of babylon as o
shining one son of morning
isaiah is likening the king's epic fall
from grace to the movement of the
morning star
which every morning appears to fall from
the sky into the underworld
in the sumerian religions of ancient
iraq the goddess inanna
was associated with the planet venus
there are several hymns of praise to
inanna in a role as the goddess the
planet
but a particularly famous hymn inanna's
descent to the underworld
describes how unlike any other deity
inanna is able to fall from heaven
descend into the netherworld and rise
back the next day
just like the planet venus does every
dusk and dawn
we've established that isaiah is
actually talking about the movements of
the morning star the planet venus
but how on earth did it become lucifer
well once the bible was translated to
latin by early christians
they came across isaiah 14 12 and
translated the hebrew word from
morningstar
into their own word for morningstar
lucifer
lucifer is a latin word for morningstar
with a word literally translating to
lightbringer in greco-roman myth
the morning star was often personified
and considered a god
and in some myths considered to be the
son of aurora
the dawn how did the star
lucifer aka venus turn so evil
and where do the fallen angels come in
to thank for that
you have the book of enoch it's an
apocryphal biblical text
written around 300-200 bce and it didn't
quite make it into the final cut of the
bible
but was incredibly popular in second
temple judaism in the book of enoch
there's a chapter called
the book of watchers and in this chapter
we have the watchers
who were dispatched to earth to watch
over humanity
but they did a terrible terrible job and
they soon began to lust for human women
and led by their leader samyaza all
started to defect from god's command
and began to procreate among human women
the offspring are called the nephilim or
giants who pillaged the earth and
endangered humanity
samyaza and his fallen angel cronies
also began to teach the humans certain
forbidden arts like weaponry cosmetics
mirrors sorceries and other hidden
secrets
meanwhile god's looking down in anger
and disbelief
so allows a great flood to rid the earth
of the corrupted humankind and those
nephilim
but first warning noah to build his ark
as described in the book of genesis
afterwards he gets his loyal angels to
punish the fallen watchers
including their evil leader samyaza
[Music]
remember none of this is actually canon
for mainstream christianity or judaism
it's labeled as an apocryphal book in
today's terms
that's the equivalent of being a sort of
bible fan fiction
but at the time people loved the book of
enoch so much
that it began to influence contemporary
religious ideas
even in the new testament book of jude
the book of enoch is directly quoted
around the time of enoch circulation
jews and early christians
rummaged through the old testament to
see if they'd missed any hidden secrets
and they just so happened to stumble on
a little verse in the book of isaiah
instead of seeing it as a reference to
the planet venus as originally intended
they found a hidden reference to that
fallen angel samyaza as seen in the book
of enoch
and when early christians read isaiah
and latin they came to understand
lucifer not as lightbringer but as a
name
a name for a fallen angel and so
lucifer the name for the fallen angel
finally stuck
and was added to a growing number of
names used for the devil such as satan
the beast beelzebub and so on now each
one of those names have their own
fascinating origins that i'd love to
cover in a future video
but for now i'll leave it to that
and that is as close of an origin story
to lucifer
as we can get it's the story of our
planet accidentally became a fallen
angel
today's bibles no longer use lucifer in
their translations
and instead use morningstar in isaiah 14
12.
the story of how lucifer got his name is
such a rabbit hole so i recommend to
explore the topic yourself
as with all my videos i've provided
links down below
if you're new here while i subscribe i
have a series of videos on my channel
that might interest you
anyway i look forward to seeing you
again for my next video
goodbye